all right it's 9:20 it's time to get
started so for the the folks wondering
about it the recording from last
Wednesday it's actually up on YouTube
now so there's a YouTube playlist linked
from if you're in the course it's it's
linked from the announcements channel
and if you're watching on twitch it's on
my twitch page alright um so today we're
gonna pick up where we left off last
time last time we started to talk about
delivery properties so the first one
that we started talking about was FIFO
delivery and we just barely managed to
start talking about it
before we had to wrap up but today we're
going to talk about it a lot more um so
let's come back to that so first of all
let's let's let's recap the difference
between between receiving and delivery
because that's something that can be
confusing
I found this confusing when I was new to
distributed systems too so so sending a
message is something you do Reese
a message is something that happens to
you but delivering a message is
something you do so if you want to you
can think about when a message is
received let's say that we have
processes a and B here in a sense be a
message you can think about there being
a little male clerk hanging out here on
process B who sees that a message has
been received and who makes a decision
about whether or not that message should
be delivered on process B and delivery
means that the the message is now
available to look at on process B so
messages could be received on process B
but then they could actually be queued
up for later delivery or they could be a
little delivered right away depending on
on the application and the needs of the
application so the so the difference
between receiving and delivery is that a
receiving is just something that happens
and you can't control when it happens
but but delivering is something that you
can do with a message that you receive
and a protocol can wait to deliver a
received message until the right time
and this is actually a really important
mechanism why might you want to queue up
a message and not read it yet
sure maybe you're working on other
things
ordering yeah that's a good one so a
message might have been received out of
order so that brings us back to so what
I wanted to talk about first today was
to talk about FIFO delivery again yeah
so so FIFO delivery and here's the
definition of it again repeating what we
had last time if a process sends message
m2 after message m1 then any process
delivering both delivers m1 first and we
set a violation of FIFO delivery would
be something that looks like this so
here there's two processes involved
process one is stenick sending two
messages you could call this M 1 and
this 1 M 2 and we're seeing here that
these messages were we haven't written
delivery explicitly in this vigor but
we're assuming that these messages got
delivered when they were received and if
so then this would be a FIFO violation
and FIFO of course stands for first in
first out
so you could think of there as being a
sort of pipe between processes or
channels we're going to call it later
and a FIFO violation would be a
violation of the order of messages in
that pipe um so a question being asked
in chat right now is how would how would
process to know that there's a problem
here if it never receives em what so
that's why this delivering both is part
of the definition of FIFO delivery so if
it never actually receives both right
then it's not a violation of FIFO
delivery because it can't deliver both
unless it receives both so if it doesn't
deliver both then the premise of this if
hasn't been satisfied and so that the
property isn't violated okay so this is
why the ability to queue up a message
and not deliver it immediately is
important for enforcing things like FIFO
delivery so as a distributed systems
implementer though you actually won't
have to implement FIFO delivery yourself
very often so why is that does anyone
know
yeah TCP is what people are mentioning
yeah it's already part of TCP so most
distributed systems communicate over TCP
probably TCP already enforces FIFO
delivery so if you need FIFO delivery it
might be a good idea to use TCP okay so
that's FIFO delivery that's kind of the
one of the most basic kinds of delivery
guarantees that we're going to talk
about what about causal delivery what
does that mean so it's going to be
something like if M ones send happens
before M to send then M ones delivery
happens before M twos delivery there are
different ways of phrasing this one but
that's a that's a phrasing that makes
sense to me so going back to that that
FIFO anomaly or actually I can just draw
it again here
so we know this is a violation of FIFO
delivery is it also a violation of
causal delivery
yeah I would say yes um because we know
right from the definition of happens
before that if no this event is before
this event on the process line then this
event back here is in the causal history
of this one right so if we want to call
these events here a and B on this first
process p1 then a is in the causal
history of B so if if we come over here
and this message gets delivered then
that delivery is happening too early so
really this message the message who send
was event a should have been delivered
before B in order for causal delivery to
hold
so our violation of FIFO delivery is
also a causal delivery violation let's
go back to our Bob smells example
so we had Allah sending a message that
said Bob smells and Bob was sending his
message in response at you Carol is
confused what kind of anomaly is this is
it a FIFO violation
FIFO violation why not well my favorite
word that I couldn't remember last time
remember vacuous so vacuously this is
not a FIFO violation because remember
the definition of a FIFO a FIFO delivery
right is if a process sends message m2
after message m1 then any process
delivering both delivers m1 first so the
same process has to be sending those two
messages to the same receiving process
right for it to be a FIFO violation and
that's what's happening here we have one
process sending two messages to the same
receiving process and they're showing up
in the wrong order but that doesn't
actually happen here because there's no
process in this picture that receives
let alone delivers two messages from the
same originating process right so Alice
is alice is sending a message to Bob and
a message to Carol Bob is sending a
message to Alice and a message to Carol
but there's no place in this picture
where there's one process that's sending
two messages to the same receiving
process so vacuously this is not a
definition excuse me this is not a
violation of of causal delivery so this
one is not not a FIFO delivery violation
but a causal delivery violation
so FIFO delivery by itself if all you
have is a system that enforces FIFO
delivery that will not by itself prevent
this kind of problem from happening it's
a causal anomaly all the interest in
causal anomalies like this one require
three or more processes to demonstrate
ah so there's a good question in chat
which is a kind of message go to
multiple definition multiple
destinations so that's kind of what's
happening here right like this message
from Alice is getting sent to both Bob
and Carol and this message from Bob is
getting sent to both Alice and Carol
so we're actually going to talk about
that more later this is what's known as
broadcast uh when somebody sends a
message and it goes to to everyone else
in the system so for now you can think
of of messages you can think of if you
want to you can think of these as being
two separate messages that were sent
right next to one another but but yeah
we're going to come back to this topic
of of broadcast very soon so here's
another correctness property that that
you might want for message delivery
totally ordered delivery if a process
delivers message m1 then m2 then all
processes delivering both m1 and m2
deliver m1 first what's in anomaly
violating this one so let's say that we
have two processes I'll call them r1 and
r2 and two clients
c1 and c2 so you can also think of as
being processes let's say that the
clients send messages to r1 and r2 and
let's just say that these clients are
sending rights to a key value store
that's replicated across these two
processes so let's say client one is
writing x equals one say client two at
the same time is writing x equals two
maybe X started out at zero
folks are complaining about the noise
level I don't know why there's more
noise today sorry about that
is it any better now
let me know if there's a problem okay so
we've got these two clients right and
they're writing these different values X
1 or x equals 1 and x equals to 2 these
two replicas where X is stored
but the updates are getting delivered in
opposite orders so let's say your
replica 1 you get this update from
client 1 it says that X is 1 little
while later you get an update from
client - that says X is 2 so you end up
thinking X is 2 meanwhile on replica -
the opposite happens right you get
client twos update that says X is 2 and
then a little while later you get this
other one that says X is 1 so two
clients are writing different values -
two replicas where X is stored and so
the updates end up game being delivered
in opposite orders now the replicas
disagree this is what we call a total
order anomaly so this is a violation of
totally ordered delivery because this
process for instance r1 delivered the
message from client one and then
diplomats from from client two so this
comes up back to that question of
broadcast for the purpose of these
definitions of delivery guarantees you
should think of these two messages that
client 1 is broadcasting here from this
same set you should think of them as
both being the same message right so you
could think of these both as being m1
and you could think of these both as
being m2 so the process here at replica
one delivered m1 and then it delivered
em two whereas replica two delivered m2
and then m1 so this is a violation of
totally ordered delivery and what we can
do at this point now that we've defined
all these different
kinds of delivery guarantees that we
that a system might want to ensure is we
we can try to put these delivery
protocols in a hierarchy in terms of
what it is that they they ensure so we
already figured out that FIFO delivery
doesn't give you causal delivery right
so coming back to our definition of
causal delivery here but on the other
hand if you're ensuring causal delivery
does that give you
FIFO delivery if I have this guarantee
if I say my system gives you causal
delivery do I know I have FIFO delivery
for sure then also
yeah you do because violations of FIFO
are also violations of causal delivery
right so if I'm ensuring causal delivery
then there won't be any violations of
FIFO delivery either so we know that's
the case so we can start to put these
things in order so at the bottom you
know we can have like the guarantee that
doesn't really guarantee anything call
it Yolo Yolo delivery one step up from
that is FIFO right this gives you the
guarantees of FIFO delivery one step up
from that is causal so if you have
causal delivery you have fivefold
delivery and and you also have and you
also have FIFO if you have causal
delivery you have FIFO delivery for free
Yolo delivery is like the empty delivery
guarantee it means there are no
guarantees
um so what about the one that I just
defined which was totally ordered
delivery where does that fit into this
picture where do you think it goes
here's a picture of a total order
anomaly again and the definition of
totally ordered delivery so where do you
think that fits in
good yeah so it would actually get its
own branch so why why is that the case
well if we look at our FIFO anomaly this
FIFO anomaly here is actually okay
in terms of totally ordered delivery so
this is a violation of FIFO delivery but
it's not a violation of totally ordered
delivery why not uh well there's only
one process here where two messages are
being delivered so if the rule is if the
rule for totally ordered delivery is all
processes delivering both M one and M
two delivery I'm one first well there's
only one process delivering both the
messages here so again this property's
vacuously this property of totally
ordered delivery is vacuously true in
this case so you could have runs that
violate FIFO but don't violate totally
ordered delivery and conversely um total
order anomalies aren't necessarily FIFO
anomalies so in back to our back to our
example here where we had these two
clients and two replicas is there any is
there anything here that's a FIFO
violation
nope there's not a case here where the
same process sends two messages to the
same receiving process so there's no
FIFO violation in this picture either
so our hierarchy of delivery guarantees
is actually going to look like this
there's actually going to be a separate
branch here for totally ordered delivery
so guarantee and causal delivery we'll
give you five oh the FIFO delivery
guarantee for free but guaranteeing
totally ordered delivery doesn't give
you either of these things and likewise
neither of these things guarantee total
order delivery for you if you if you
wanted to have both causal delivery and
totally ordered delivery you would have
to define some other special delivery
guarantee which would then be at the top
of this hierarchy so what we want to do
next is kind of start to talk about
implementing these protocols and so this
is going to be the topic of discussion
for the next couple of lectures but
today we can get started on on talking
about at least implementation of FIFO
delivery which also again is the one
that you you won't have to do too often
but let's talk about it
okay so somebody's asking what is this
hierarchy imply exactly so before we go
on to talk about implementation let's
talk about this a little bit more so
let's give this a name hierarchy of
delivery guarantees
what does it imply well since we see
that causal is higher up than FIFO
delivery we know that if a system
guarantees causal delivery then it also
gives you FIFO delivery since by if I
was lower down than causal we know that
if the system guarantees FIFO deliveries
we have no guarantees with respect to
causal delivery maybe the system does
give you causal delivery but the FIFO
guarantee by itself doesn't provide that
and then if the system provides totally
ordered delivery well that's great and
useful but by itself it doesn't imply
that there's either FIFO or causal
delivery so this hierarchy tells you
something about what it is that you can
expect out of a particular delivery
guarantee it also tells you something
about what if you if you have a an
anomaly than what what kind of anomaly
it counts as right so if we have a
violation of FIFO then that's also a
violation of causal delivery because
FIFO appears below causal in this
picture but if we have a violation of
FIFO it's not a violent necessarily a
violation of totally ordered delivery as
we just saw here okay so let's let's
start to talk about how to implement
FIFO delivery let's say that you wanted
to rule out this kind of anomaly how
would you go about it so here's the
definition of FIFO delivery again if a
process sends message m2 after message
m1 any process delivering both delivers
m1 first so there's an equivalent way to
put that which we could say messages
that come from the same sender
are delivered at
any process delivering both in the order
that they were sent okay suggestions on
what to do to implement this there's
already one one suggestion in chat which
is sequence numbers so sequence numbers
are a typical approach to implementing
FIFO delivery so what sequence numbers
we say messages get tagged with a
sequence number from the sender and a
sender ID and the sender incremental
after Sandy
so that's what the center does what is
the receiver do
yeah the Sivir wants to keep some sort
of cue so what are the rules for when
the Sivir actually delivered the the the
receiver actually delivers a message
versus queuing it up
right so we want it for every received
message
we want to look at its sequence number
and we want to ask is that sequence
number is it the sequence number of the
previous previously delivered message
from that sender sorry SN plus one if a
received messages sequence number is the
sequence number plus one of the
previously delivered message from that
sender deliver it otherwise queue it
queue it up for later so this is one way
to implement FIFO delivery in the way
that I've sketched it out here what are
some situations where this would would
not work
you
yeah what if a message gets lost right
so let's say this let's say we have
Alice and Bob and suppose Alice is
sending messages to Bob and so she's
happily sending them and giving them
sequence numbers maybe this is message y
and Bob gets it he delivers it message
to Bob receives it and delivers it and
so on let's say Allah sends message
three and then that message gets lost
for some reason well message for comes
along because Alice doesn't know that
that message got lost right message for
comes along but Bob can't deliver it
right because Bob never delivered
message three so this one would just get
queued message five would get queued and
so on right so these later messages
would end up being buffered forever
right if a message got lost so this
strategy that we just sketched out for
five ho delivery here it is again this
only works if you also have reliable
delivery of messages so we'll talk more
about reliable delivery later but but
this is this is an approach that would
only work assumes reliable delivery
so somebody asked about these sequence
numbers so when you send a message so
sequence numbers don't necessarily have
to be globally unique right because we
were saying that when these messages get
sent they also come with the the sender
ID so the combination of the sender ID
and the sequence number ought to be
ought to be globally unique right but
everybody should be able to use this the
same the same numbers as their sequence
numbers here all right so that's one way
of implementing a FIFO delivery it's
it's it's not necessarily the only way
what's another way that we could
implement 500 delivery other than
sequence numbers
actually but before we talk about that
um let's uh for the sake of argument um
let's just talk about suppose you didn't
have reliable delivery how would you
implement FIFO delivery well one thing
you could do is you could just go ahead
and deliver like let's say we have this
picture here you could just say go ahead
and delivery any message that has a
sequence number larger than the one
delivered before right so here Bob got a
message was sequence number one and
delivered it got a message to a sequence
number two and delivered it a message
with sequence number three didn't arrive
then suppose Bob gets this message of a
sequence number four Bob could go ahead
and deliver it right and the same with
five but if it turned out that this
message three wasn't in fact lost and
was just delayed then three would come
up later like here maybe then under this
approach we would have to just drop that
message on Bob's end when it arrives and
you could imagine a system that did that
right or you could imagine a system that
kind of makes it an intermediate choice
right and buffers messages any messages
that are received out of order it might
like buffer them for a while
like maybe in this case he would buffer
up these messages four and five for a
little while waiting on message three to
arrive and then you would deliver three
four and five in that order but you have
to pick the buffer size right if you
only had a buffer that was big enough
for one message then you wouldn't be
able to do that and so this this
question of buffer size ends up being an
important design decision in these kinds
of systems here's another point to make
about this about FIFO delivery Oh what
if you had this what if
what if Alice sends a bunch of messages
and maybe some of them cross over like
this but Bob doesn't actually deliver
any of them if Bob just drops them all
if that's what happens is this a
violation of FIFO delivery or in other
words am I am I guaranteeing FIFO
delivery in this picture
you
sure yeah so no message is actually get
delivered so it vacuously satisfies that
that FIFO correctness property but this
is really unsatisfying isn't it
so no messages are getting delivered at
all so I haven't violated FIFO delivery
and later in the course we're going to
talk about safety properties versus
liveness properties which is which is
relevant to this okay that was a
digression back to this question about
about implementing FIFO so a couple
people in chat have already suggested
another possibility for implementing
FIFO and as an alternative to sequence
numbers so another way to implement FIFO
delivery acknowledgments so in the
acknowledgment approach we have our
sender in our receiver Alice sends a
message and there's actually no need for
her to send a sequence number and Bob
sends back an acknowledgement okay I got
it when Alice gets that acknowledgement
back she knows that it's okay to send
another message and then she waits again
to get the okay I got it
acknowledgement and so on so Alice won't
send her message too until she gets the
acknowledgement of message one
so perhaps Alice knows that there's an
order to these messages over here but
she's not she doesn't have to send the
sequence numbers along with the messages
this time so this doesn't require Alice
to send sequence numbers and it doesn't
require Bob to keep track of what
sequence number he last saw from Alice
because the work of deciding when to
send a message is all taking place on
Alex's analysis end but what's the
downside of doing it this way
it's slow yeah
so unlike before when Alice could just
fire off messages with sequence numbers
and not wait for a response it's slow so
that's not great all right
so there are optimizations that you can
do sure so some people are making
suggestions like you can batch up
messages and so on yeah so and that is
indeed what real systems do so but
there's these fundamental difficulties
right with implementing FIFO right you
have to make a choice you know you can
either do this approach where you wait
for acknowledgments and it's slow or you
do the sequence number approach which
requires some queuing to be done on the
receiving end possibly or it requires
some requires some bookkeeping or you
could do both right but and and then
there's these optimizations that you can
do such as batching messages and so on
but these the the the fundamental
difficulty of having to do this and
needing reliable delivery in order to
make this work is pretty unavoidable
okay so that's by food delivery but for
the most part we can think of it as a
solved problem right and if this were a
networking class we could we could dig
really deeply into the the internals of
TCP and so forth but this is not a
networking class so let's talk instead
about something that's that's maybe a
little bit more interesting which is
causal delivery so here's again what our
classic causal anomaly looks like
so the fundamental issue here right is
that is that this this fu message was
delivered on Carol before the Bob smells
message even though it was causally
later anybody have a suggestion for how
you could prevent that
hmm
you
so a suggestion is global sequence
number per message so I'm already a
little bit skeptical of that suggestion
because of the word global so I don't
know how you would come up with these
global sequence numbers time stamps okay
so we're getting a little bit closer to
what I want but we want them to be
logical time stamps right because we
don't really have a we don't have a
mechanism for global time stamps so the
the solution that we can actually use to
ensure causal delivery in this situation
is with vector clocks we can use vector
clocks to rule out this causal anomaly
or any causal anomaly so we're going to
talk about that a little bit more let's
pause and do a quiz question right now
so here's the link to the quiz and chat
we'll wait a couple more minutes
you
okay
so let's come back to this discussion of
how we would go about implementing
causal delivery using vector clocks
which are the mechanism that we started
to talk about before for tracking
causality so before when we talked about
vector clocks right we used them to
track every event right we used them to
track message tons message receives and
so on so the picture that I showed
previously of assigning vector clocks to
events in a LAN port diagram every event
counted as an event in order to
implement causal delivery we can change
the way that we use vectors vector
clocks slightly so we're only going to
track message sends and it turns out
that that's actually sufficient to to
ensure causal delivery so with this
caveat that we only have to track
message sends we don't have to consider
message receives as events let's
actually try to attach some vector
clocks to the events in this picture and
let's see if we can kind of Intuit how
vector clocks could be used to prevent
this causal anomaly okay so recall from
our discussion of vector clocks that
everybody starts out with a local vector
clock initialized to zero
so Carol has a local vector clock of
zero zero zero and Bob has one of zero
zero zero and Alice has one of zero zero
zero okay
Alice sends her BS message what time
stamp does that message have or what
vector clock does that message have
attached to it
right it should be one zero zero because
she's now sent one message right so she
increments her own position uh in her
local clock the message gets to Bob his
local clock is at zero zero zero is this
message right here uh is it okay for Bob
to deliver that message this first Bob
smells message from Alice intuitively
yes right because it's the same as his
own local clock except it's higher by
one in one position which position the
position of the process that the message
is coming from so that's okay right so
Bob can go ahead and deliver that
message there that gets a checkmark now
Bob sends a message
what's the clock on that message well
it's gonna be one one zero so that shows
that he's aware of one message sent by
Alice right this previous one and he's
also aware of this message sent by
himself so that one one zero is going to
be the vector clock of this event right
here and that vector clock gets attached
to the message as it gets sent out the
message gets to Alice is it okay for
Alice to deliver it at that point
sure yeah because it's the same as
Alice's local clock of one zero zero
except plus one in this in one position
which again is that is the position of
the process the message is coming from
so that's okay
so it can get delivered there alright
but it's a message for from Bob okay for
Carol to deliver this is the key
question right here so the message
coming from Bob has this clock of one
one zero
Carol's local clock is zero zero zero so
actually no it's not okay for Carol to
deliver that message because this vector
clock of one one zero is too big in
particular the entry for Alice is too
big the message is from Bob right so we
would expect it to be higher than
whatever Carol currently has in her
entry for Bob which is zero in
particular if it's just one higher than
what carol has currently for Bob then
that's fine right but this message of
with this one one zero vector clock on
it is also one higher than what carol
has in the Alice position uh meaning
that it's from the future in some sets
so Carol should not deliver it she has
to buffer it then finally
bs message right from Alice gets to
Carol can she deliver that one sure yeah
so it's clock its vector clock is 1 zero
zero so it's the same as Carol's clock
except that it's plus one in the
sender's position so that's fine and
then at that point now that we've
received this one zero zero message now
we can go back and look at the one that
we buffered right which was one one zero
and we can check if it can be delivered
and it can at this point because now
it's clock is the same as the local
clock except plus one in the sender's
position so this message here kind of
gets delayed until down here where it
can get delivered so it's now okay to
deliver now that we've delivered this
one
questions about that
question and chat is shouldn't the
second event on Bob's processed line be
one to zero
ah
so that's where this comes in where I
say we're old we only have to track
message sends so this here actually
doesn't count as an event on Bob because
it's a receive so we're only counting
sends as events in this algorithm so
you're right it would have been one to
zero if this in fact had if we had been
counting message receives as events and
yeah we're always gonna whenever we ask
you to assign vector clocks or any kind
of logical clock to messages then an
important thing to specify in advance
then as well what counts as an event
right so in this case for this picture
we're saying only message sends count as
events in the vector clocks algorithm
that I showed earlier both sons and
receives counts as event as events and
what you choose to do right is going to
depend on what you're actually trying to
accomplish so here's another question in
chat if Alice only sent Bob smells to
Bob but Bob sent this message fu to both
Alice and Carol would Carol still buffer
the message from Bob well Carol would
not have received the the BS message
right so then it wouldn't matter right
yeah so in that case if Alice says Bob
smells to Bob and then Bob decides for
some reason to say to say fu to both
Ellis and Carol well and Bob is choosing
to say fu to somebody who wasn't
involved right so I guess that's Bob's
prerogative but that wouldn't be a
causal anomaly that would just be Bob
being a jerk
alright so there's a question on twitch
chat which is does this assume that all
sends our broadcasts thank you for
asking
absolutely yeah so I haven't specified
this entire method yet exactly for for
ensuring causal delivery of messages but
and we'll sketch it out next time but in
the version that I've sort of informally
discussed here this is actually an
algorithm for causal broadcast so the
approach that I've sketched out here
actually only works if all messages are
broadcast messages good question so
maybe I guess we have we have a couple
minutes left and I don't think it's
enough time to actually more formally
write down what the protocol is that
we're using for causal broadcast but I
want to try to answer one more question
from from slack which was does Carroll's
vector clock ever change when receiving
a message if not why does it stay the
same so yeah so I hadn't been updating
these local clocks here and we we should
be updating them right so even though
message receives don't count as events
we're still following the usual vector
clock algorithm algorithm right we're
when we receive a message it comes with
a clock and then we update our local
clock to the maximum right so for
example here when when Bob sends this
message and it has this one zero zero
vector clock or excuse me when Alice
sends this message and it has this one
zero zero clock attached to it then
Bob's local clock right should update to
one zero zero here and then when this
message here gets sent that's why this
one is one one zero because he's
incrementing his own position and then
when Carol receives this message this
one doesn't get delivered right so that
one gets queued and that one kind of
gets
ignore it until later but when this one
arrives with the one zero zero now this
position gets updated to one and then
that's what makes it possible to deliver
this other message which had the the one
one zero time stamp on it because it
gets compared with Carroll's local clock
all right yeah and another good point
being made in chat is is we're also
we're also assuming reliable delivery of
messages here so just like our our our
FIFO delivery mechanism assumed both of
the FIFO delivery mechanisms that we
that we talked about both sequence
numbers and acknowledgments they both
assumed that message delivery is
reliable right so there's there's an
assumption here about about message
delivery being reliable as well so you
can imagine that these systems are built
on a sort of stack of assumptions right
that each have to build on one another
and we haven't even talked yet about how
to implement reliable delivery so that's
something that's that we're going to
talk about much more later on when we
start to talk about failure more all
right so that's it for today next time
we're gonna sketch out or next time
we're going to we're going to talk about
this causal broadcast algorithm in more
detail and then we'll start to talk a
little bit more about the total the
total order anomaly that we talked about
today and why it is that it's that that
these sorts of mechanisms for ensuring
causal delivery and so on don't ensure
totally ordered delivery see you next
time